(upbeat music)
There's always room for dessert.
Here's a sweet idea just for you.
Hi Drew, I'm Capri Lilly, creator of Good Food Baddie
and today, I'll be showing you how to make
these spooky pumpkin ice cream cookie sandwiches.
Here I have homemade double chocolate chip cookies
and they're gonna serve as the base
for our pumpkin ice cream cookie sandwiches.
Right now, I'm gonna show you
how to make your own pumpkin nice cream at home.
I'm gonna start off by adding to the pumpkin puree.
Then I'll add coconut cream, maple syrup, pumpkin spice,
cinnamon, coconut sugar, and blend until it's smooth.
Then I'll place it in the bread pan
and place it in the freezer for two hours.
And now I have this delicious, smooth,
creamy pumpkin spice nice cream.
Now, we'll take a scoop of the ice cream
and place it on top of our double chocolate chip cookies
and then use another cookie
to finish and complete the sandwich.
And we're all done.
We have these spooky pumpkin spice
ice cream cookie sandwiches.
Wow, I'm in a delicious food coma just from watching that!
(upbeat music)